I'm no pushover sweetie right so do a
five last round is sort of the final
book in title to the series and we've
had three iterations since launch in
2012 we had do a five plus on Vita we
have do a five ultimate based on the
Japanese arcade version that people are
currently playing and since then we've
also had a ton of DLC in terms of
content costumed characters and this
particular game will provide all of that
in one package and it's also a really
sort of a value proposition in the fact
that you're getting almost close to 400
costumes plus two new stages two new
characters and the price point is 29 99
for last gen system and 39 99 for
current-gen systems and obviously the
graphics is going to be played at 60
frames 1080p in terms of reworkings of
the graphics we didn't really feel that
we needed to do much of it because
really pushed the boundaries when we
release this back in ps3 and 360
obviously there are some polishes that
some of the core players will notice and
pick up certainly the new stages that we
have crimson and danger zone really
shows off the power of the current gen
systems so this is crimson it's a brand
new stage from us and this kind of
epitomizes what do a5 is all about so
it's really you know showing off the
interactive stages the multi-tiered
levels we're trying to provide sort of a
cinematic experience to a fight so as
you can see when things start moving
it'll start triggering different touch
points within the state
environments will change for people who
aren't familiar one of the things you'll
notice is as the fight it progresses the
players pick up debris they sweat and
there's sort of that wear and tear
aspect to the fight so danger zone is a
stage where it's very much the flooring
in itself all the blue areas of the
stage is a hot spot if you if you strike
and as you can see and land your
opponent on that it triggers a bounce
and it causes so much more damage than
you would normally do and for expert
players they would be able to juggle you
in a string of combos and keep you
midair and continue to punish so I think
it's it's really sort of something that
the it's fun to watch in a competitive
scene but also it's a fan favorite back
in the day and we just brought it into
much more of a bigger and much more
powerful manner and in this sense though
also one of the things that we are known
for with doa5 and it's showing up again
in last round is the fact that there's a
special move called power blow which
after you get a below a half bar on your
lifeline it gives you sort of a comeback
option where if you press a combination
of buttons and those button prompts are
different for each character it allows
you to do the special sort of move where
it's followed by a little bit of a fancy
QuickTime event and it launches a
character into sort of wherever
directional area that you want to point
it and it takes a considerable amount of
life so do a five last round for
everybody who's been supporting this
this is basically the bookend to our
series for do a five it is a packed sort
of title with so much content for you
guys to enjoy for a very long time like
I said over 300 costumes to new stages
to new costumes the resolution has been
bumped up to 1080p 60 frames we will be
supporting you guys with even more
content after the game is released core
fighters is also a great way for you
guys to check out the game without
purchasing the full price point it's
releasing next year februari 17 on
station for Xbox one and digital
download purchases for ps3 and xbox 360